[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und wir
beginnen die Sendung mit dem Sport denn
dass wir im Aus für die deutschen
Fußballerin ist natürlich die große
Nachricht heute und darüber sprechen
gleich mit Sven Voß ja auch von mir
einen schönen guten Abend an einem Tag
der für alle die es mit der deutschen
Frauenfußball Nationalmannschaft halt
nicht so schön ist das stimmt wir
schauen uns die Themen genauer an
aus der Traum so früh wie nie scheitern
die deutschen Frauen bei einer
Fußballweltmeisterschaft
[Applaus]
Rotstift bei der Digitalisierung der
Bund will weniger Geld für die
Modernisierung der Verwaltung
bereitstellen
und im sicheren Hafen der der Nordsee
havarierte Auto Frachter ist ins
niederländische Emshaven geschleppt
worden
Schock Enttäuschung Fassungslosigkeit
bei den deutschen Fußballerinnen und
ihren Fans ausgeschieden in der WM
Vorrunde ein historisch schlechtes
Ergebnis wie Bundestrainerin fast
Tecklenburg eingesteht das 1:1 gegen
Außenseite Südkorea war zu wenig über
das WM aus Michael Spindler
leere Blicke und Ratlosigkeit bei den
deutschen Spielerinnen nach einem
historischen WM-Debakel das Fragen
aufwirft heute hat unsere Leistung nicht
ausgereicht um diese Spiele zu gewinnen
war sehr nervös sehr fahrig sehr
ja einfach auf vielen vielen Bereichen
heute in den Basics nicht ausreichend
die DFB-Elf wirkte überrascht von der
ungewohnt offensiven Spielweise der
südkoreanerinnen die schon in der
sechsten Minute den Führungstreffer
erzielten soll und schon nutzt die
fehlende Zuordnung in der deutschen
Abwehr zum 1:0 es dauerte bis zur 42
minute ehe Alexandra Popp per Kopf den
ersehnten Ausgleich zum 1:1 erzielte ein
Tor das Hoffnung machte doch die
Ernüchterung folgte schon in der
Halbzeitpause auf dem Weg in die Kabine
denn den Parallelspiel gegen Marokko per
Elfmeter gegen Kolumbien mit 1:0 in
Führung das deutsche Unentschieden damit
zu wenig ein Sieg musste erher Alexandra
Popp lässt die Herzen noch mal höher
schlagen mit ihrem vermeintlichen
Treffer zum 2:1 doch die Szene wird per
Video Beweis überprüft abseits das Tor
zählt nicht Deutschland kann das Spiel
nicht mehr drehen und scheidet erstmals
bei einer WM nach der Gruppenphase aus
ich weiß auch gar nicht was ich
großartig sagen soll irgendwie weil
[Musik]
ja ist noch nicht so ganz verstehen kann
was er jetzt gerade abgeht um ehrlich zu
sein für andere begann die Aufarbeitung
dieser WM schon direkt nach dem Spiel
ich möchte jetzt gar nicht zu sehr auch
in irgendwas gedrängt werden was dann
auch nicht richtig wäre weil es
vielleicht auch sehr Emotion jetzt
heraus geschieht die WM Blamage der
Frauen fügt sich nahtlos in die Pleiten
der Männer und der U21 ein der DFB muss
Antworten finden wir hatten gebrauchten
Sommer innerhalb auch unseres DFBs mit
vielen Rückschlägen jetzt auch bei den
Frauen und ja da gilt es einfach für uns
die Themen zu analysieren der deutsche
Fußball ist jetzt wohl endgültig im
Mittelmaß angekommen
und viele Fans haben ja heute gemeinsam
auf Leinwänden das Spiel Deutschland
Südkorea verfolgt mitgefiebert und
mitgelitten wo man Lesko war in Berlin
dabei
Opfer in Berliner Biergarten der
Schrecken ist in die Gesichter
geschrieben bei Klein und Groß
muss man das Aufarbeiten woran
Gelegenheit man hat natürlich gegen
Südkorea Erne
etwas bessere Leistung erwartet man
hätte den Sieg erwartet weil sie Korea
auch kein Gruppenspiel gewonnen hat bis
jetzt dabei war das Interesse schon vor
Beginn groß noch bevor der Biergarten
öffnet stehen die ersten vor der Tür die
Tische waren trotz schlechter
Wetteraussichten bereits Tage zuvor
reserviert das fünf Jahre nachdem
wm-ausscheiden der Männer gegen Südkorea
die Frauen folgen könnten für die
meisten Vorspiel beginnt ausgeschlossen
[Musik]
höher ist für die Spielerin zu spielen
oder auch eben jetzt diese drei Punkte
noch mitzunehmen sind die Frauen sind
schon ein bisschen kerniger ne doch was
folgt ist die große Ernüchterung
Enttäuschung nach dem Führungstreffer
der südkoreanerinnen in Berlin oder im
Dortmunder Fußballmuseum
der Jubel über den Ausgleich kurz vor
der Halbzeit werd nur kurz der zweite
Abschnitt wird zur Zitterpartie und
Berlin zwischenzeitlich vom Regen
eingeholt auch manche Fan sieht nun
düstere Wolken an Deutschlands
Fußballhimmel
wie bei den Frauen wir kriegen nicht
eine eigene Spielidee auf dem Platz
vereinzelt sah man hinterher auch
freudige Gesichter die große Siegesfeier
aber viel heute buchstäblich ins Wasser
das war es jetzt also die dfb-frau
müssen die Heimreise antreten Sven woran
hat es denn gelegen das sind erstmal nur
Erklärungsversuche was die deutsche
Mannschaft hatte war eine gute Moralen
guten Teamspirit und Alexandra poppt die
die wichtigen Tore macht aber das hat
nicht gereicht denn was wir gefehlt hat
waren Lösungen gegen Gegnerinnen wie
Südkorea oder auch Kolumbien die zu 90
Prozent verteidigen aber zu 10% wissen
wie sie der deutschen Mannschaft weh tun
können nämlich mit Toren und zweimal hat
sie deutsche Mannschaft nicht geschafft
aus dem Rückstand noch ein Sieg zu
machen für die Frauen bei den Männern
läuft irgendwie auch nicht wirklich was
ist denn da los im deutschen
Profifußball naja bei den Frauen muss
man sagen da geht's um wichtige Dinge
man muss jetzt erstmal die Euphorie
mitnehmen die trotz des Ausscheidens ja
da ist beim Thema Frauenfußball und dann
müssen DFB und auch die Liga also die
Clubs an einem Strang ziehen und müssen
weiter professionalisieren sie müssen
investieren in den Frauenfußball in die
Bedingungen für die deutschen
Fußballerinnen und dann kann das auch
wieder was werden das beste Beispiel ist
da England da hat man viel investiert in
die Englisch e Frauen Liga und das hat
sich dann auch ausgezahlt für die
englische Nationalmannschaft die sind
schließlich weiter danke
und so viel heute zum Sport jetzt
blicken wir auf ein Thema das viele von
ihnen sicher aus eigener Erfahrung
kennen zum Beispiel beim Beantragen
eines neuen Personalausweises es geht um
die Digitalisierung von Verwaltungen
denn da hängt Deutschland deutlich
hinterher das zeigt europäische
Vergleich innerhalb der EU belegt
Deutschland nur Platz 19 und jetzt soll
auch noch drastisch gekürzt werden
dieses Jahr liegt der Etat für die
Digitalisierung von Verwaltungen bei 377
Millionen Euro nächstes Jahr nur bei
rund 3 Millionen was das für
Auswirkungen hat zeigt lass wohnsack
Alena Bata studiert
Politikwissenschaften an der Unihalle
und ist auf BAföG angewiesen zwar kann
sie den Antrag online stellen bis der
aber genehmigt ist kann es dauern ich
musste vier Monate auf meinen Bafög
warten der Weg von der Antragstellung
bis zur wirklichen Auszahlungen viel zu
lang und ja unausbar für das waren so
300 € weg waren die nicht da waren
war es natürlich wieder über die Wunden
zu kommen der Grund für die lange
Bearbeitungsdauer im Bafög-Amt werden
die Anträge nicht digital verarbeitet
sondern ausgedruckt und in Ordnung
abgelegt bereits 2017 wurde das Online
zugangsgesetz verabschiedet dass sie
Digitalisierung der Verwaltung bis Ende
2022 vorantreiben sollte doch bis heute
sind von 575 Verwaltungsleistungen die
Bafög-Antrag oder Kfz-Zulassung gerade
mal 128 umgesetzt selbst die eigenen
Beraterinnen waren in die Regierung ver
Kürzungen das ist tatsächlich Spahn am
falschen Ende das haben wir anders
empfohlen hier muss ich sagen hat man
wirklich die falsche Entscheidung
getroffen kritik kommt auch von der
Opposition Deutschland sei längst ins
digitale Hintertreffen geraten
das kostet uns Zeit das kostet uns Geld
das kostet uns Zukunftschancen und wir
können natürlich anstehende Krisen von
Krieg Corona bis zur Klimakrise nicht so
schnell wie wir müssten bewältigen weil
es mit faxen und stempeln einfach viel
zu lange dauert zwar hat das
Innenministerium mittlerweile
angekündigt die Mittel anderweitig zu
beschaffen an den grundsätzlichen
Defiziten wird das aber erstmal wenig
ändern
nicht alle Menschen die nach Deutschland
kommen in der Hoffnung auf ein sicheres
oder besseres Leben dürfen auch bleiben
im ersten Halbjahr sind etwa 15%
derjenigen die das Land verlassen
müssten abgeschoben worden und es
Innenministerin Veser schlägt schärfere
Regeln vor und Ernte Zuspruch und Kritik
Patricia Wiedemeier berichtet
geht es nach der Innenministerin sollen
Menschen die kein Recht auf Asyl haben
künftig nicht bis zu zehn sondern 28
Tage in Gewahrsam bleiben können um den
Behörden mehr Zeit zu geben die
Abschiebung vorzubereiten die FDP
begrüßt den Vorschlag die Grünen jedoch
kritisieren dass ein anderer Zeitplan
verabredet sei wir hatten ja auch ein
bisschen mehr vereinbart tatsächlich im
Herbst das sogenannte migrationspakets 2
zu diskutieren und auch zum Beispiel der
Familiennachzug und nicht nur
restriktive Maßnahmen zum Thema
Einwanderung und Integration diskutiert
werden sollen ein Problem ist immer noch
das für die Ausländerbehörden ein
Problem besteht innerhalb der kurzen
Zeit die eine Person im haushaltige
Wahrsagen ist reisepapier dazu
geschaffen ein Flugzeug organisieren die
Rücknahme auf der anderen Seite
sicherzustellen wenn dafür mehr Zeit ist
werden glücklich auch mehr Abschiebungen
gelingen zum Stichtag 30 Juni waren laut
Innenministerium
279.000 Ausländer ausreisepflichtig
knapp 225 hatten jedoch eine Duldung da
sie entweder keine Dokumente hatten
krank waren oder von ihren
Herkunftsländern nicht zurückgenommen
werden für Länder Kommunen und Polizei
das eigentliche Problem wir in Sachsen
wären darauf angewiesen dass wir
zunächst mal den Zugang begrenzen das
heißt dass man bei der
bundesinnenministerin angeforderte
Grenzkontrollen wir wären darauf
angewiesen dass wir in mehr Länder
abschieben können und wir mehr
Rückführung organisieren will der
braucht dafür auch einfach schlicht und
ergreifend mehr Personal die
bundesinnenministerin hatte 500
zusätzliche rückführerstellen beim
Bundeshaushalt gefordert der
Bundesfinanzminister hat sich dazu
geknöpft gezeigt jetzt sei die Politik
gefordert aber noch handelt es sich ja
auch nur um ein Diskussionspapier
aufatmen an der Nordsee der havarierte
Auto Frachter free mental Highway ist
erfolgreich in einen Hafen im Norden der
Niederlande an der Grenze zu Deutschland
geschleppt worden damit endet auch die
Sorge dass das Schiff auf sie
auseinanderbrechen und sinken könnte was
eine Umweltkatastrophe bedeutet hätte
Lena sünderbruch
die Gefahr ist vorerst gebannt
wetterströmung und Gezeiten können der
freemantel Highway nun fast nichts mehr
anhaben angetreut im niederländischen
Emshaven
wir sind sehr froh dass die Reise
erfolgreich verlaufen ist die ganze
Reise vom frühen Morgen bis zum
Nachmittag lief ohne irgendwelche
Zwischenfälle
das stark beschädigte Schiff war
tagelang Brennen in der Nordsee
getrieben ein Mann der Besatzung starb
dabei dann wurde der Frachter zunächst
zu einem notankerplatz nördlich der
niederländischen Wattenmeerinsel
schamonnikoog gebracht heute zogen zwei
Schlepper das ausgebrannte Schiff die
verbleibenden 60 km in den Nordsee Hafen
an der Emsmündung begleitet von weiteren
boten auch deutschen und einem Flugzeug
der Küstenwache
einerseits finde ich großartig und
wirklich so wie ein kleines Wunder
andererseits fand ich schon auch sehr
bedrohlich so dieses große Schiff zu
sehen und diese vielen Begleitfahrzeuge
an Bord befinden sich noch immer 3.800
Autos und 1,6 Millionen Liter Schweröl
für das Weltnaturerbe Watten mehr wäre
ein Kentern des Frachters verheerend
gewesen nach wie vor ist dieses Schiff
stark beschädigt und es ist halt nach
wie vor große Mengen an Treibstoff und
eben diese
verbrannten oder zum Teil vielleicht
auch noch
fehlenden Autos an Bord so dass wir
nicht vollständig ausschließen können
dass auch nach wie vor Schadstoffe in
die Umwelt gelangen können bis Mitte
Oktober soll die freemantel Highway in
Emshaven bleiben sie wird entladen und
die Schadstoffe entsorgt
und vor Ort in Eemshaven ist für uns da
wieder Römhild David was genau passiert
dann nun auf dem Schiff
das Schiff liegt zunächst einmal hier
relativ sicher und stabil hinter mir an
Bord sind 21 Grad es gibt keine Hotspots
das Feuer ist aus das hat der
Hafenkapitän mehr gerade noch mal
bestätigt und auch die Luft an Bord die
wird regelmäßig kontrolliert damit
Experten an Bord gehen können vielleicht
sieht man das hinter mir mit diesen
roten Krähen sind Experten der
Versicherung der Feuerwehr und des
Bergungsunternehmen hier den ganzen
Nachmittag über an Bord geliefert worden
um sich einen Überblick zu verschaffen
und man sieht vielleicht auch ganz gut
am Heck des Schiffes wo das Feuer
gewählte gewütet hat nämlich aufwärts
von Deck 5 möglicherweise sind die Autos
darunter die Ladung noch relativ intakt
das muss jetzt erstmal geklärt werden
man sieht auch dass die freemantel
Highway hier noch deutlich Schlagseite
hat das liegt daran dass ein Teil der
Ladung verrutscht ist und das ist
Löschwasser in das Schiff gelaufen ist
das muss zunächst erstmal abgepumpt
werden genau wie der Treibstoff der noch
an Bord ist dann kann man möglicherweise
etwas zu Brandursache sagen und dann
kann mit der Werbung der Fracht begonnen
werden das kann aber durchaus noch Tage
oder eine Woche dauern danke
die Bundeswehr hat 50 Menschen aus Niger
ausgeflogen die USA und Großbritannien
haben angekündigt Botschaftspersonal
abzuziehen am heutigen
Unabhängigkeitstag demonstrierten
hunderte Menschen im Niger gegen die
ehemalige Kolonialmacht Frankreich und
den westafrikanischen Wirtschaftsbund
ECOWAS diese hatte Sanktionen verhängt
und mit militärischer Intervention
gedroht sollte der abgesetzte Staatschef
bei Zoom bis Sonntag nicht wieder
eingesetzt sein
das iranische Regime will die Strafen
nochmal drastisch verschärfen für Frauen
die kein Kopftuch tragen oder es nicht
so tragen wie die sogenannten
sittenwächters haben möchten monatelang
hat es ja Massenproteste gegen die
Kopftuchpflicht und das Regime gegeben
wie die Iranerin jetzt auf die
umstrittene strafreform reagieren
berichtet
diese Bilder wären nur 100 Kilometer
ostwärts im Iran und denkbar Männer und
Frauen tanzen gemeinsam leicht bekleidet
Schaumparty in der türkischen Grenzstadt
Touristen
im Iran sitzen sie uns massiv unter
Druck insbesondere die Sittenpolizei sie
zwingen uns uns komplett zu bedecken
[Musik]
hier machen sie Ferien in der Freiheit
Ferien von einem Land das in diesen
Tagen ein Gesetz vorbereitet das Frauen
noch härter bestrafen will wenn sie sich
nicht an die islamische Kleiderordnung
halten Teheran obwohl die Sittenpolizei
in den vergangenen Wochen massiv
verstärkt wurde sind auch an diesem
Morgen wieder Frauen ohne die Job
unterwegs nun arbeitet das Regime an
noch härteren Strafen bei mehrfacher
Missachtung der islamischen
Kleidungsregeln etwa Geldbußen von
umgerechnet rund 950 € in Extremfällen
sogar bis zu 15 Jahre Haft doch Eindruck
scheint das hier wenig zu machen
die Menschen treten gut daran wieder auf
die Straße zu gehen und ihre Rechte zu
verteidigen
wenn wir es durchziehen werden wir
Freiheit bekommen Meinungsfreiheit
Freiheit in der Kleidung das ist sicher
zurück in wann sein Protest ist Party
Babak ist DJ im Iran wurde er mehrfach
inhaftiert wegen Ungehorsam er Flo in
die Türkei ausgerechnet hier trifft er
sie wieder die einzigen Unterdrücker
immer wieder sehe ich unter den
Feiernden die Milizen der iranischen
Revolution gaben im Iran unterdrücken
sie hier feiern sie das macht mich so
wütend
Wut und Trauer darüber dass ihre
Freiheit nur in den Ferien gelebt werden
kann außerhalb der Landesgrenze
[Musik]
nach Bosnien und Herzegowina dort ist
heute der serbische Präsident Vucic zu
Gast ein Besuch der die Spannungen in
dem multi-ethnischen Balkanstaat weiter
verschärfen könnte denn seit Kriegsende
1995 besteht Bosnien und Herzegowina aus
zwei etwa gleich großen autonomen Teilen
verbunden durch eine schwache
Zentralregierung
in der Föderation Bosnien und
Herzegowina stellen die Börsenjahr und
Kroaten die Mehrheit in der Republica
dominieren die Serben dort regiert mit
miloric ein Politiker der das fragile
Staatsgebiet derzeit zu spalten versucht
Wolf Christian Ulrich
der neue Kindergarten heißt Serbien was
aussieht wie ein harmloses treffen ist
ein knallharter Kampf um die Macht in
Bosnien und Herzegowina
präsentiert hohen Besuch aus Belgrad der
klarstellt
wir sind ein Volk nur auf beiden Seiten
der Trainer
in der republikation
Handwerk lernte er bei Putin berichten
Journalisten die hier inzwischen stark
unter Druck stehen
hat die Kontrolle über die Justiz die
Bildung des Gesundheitssystem und was
uns Journalisten angeht ich hatte schon
eine Morddrohung aus seinem Umfeld
mit neuen Gesetzen setzt die Axt nun an
die Einheit von Bosnien und Herzegowina
selbst das Verfassungsgericht will er
nicht mehr anerkennen
als nächstes kommen der Geheimdienst und
die Staatsanwaltschaft dran kündigt
neulich an Beobachter sind alarmiert
gefährliche Situation und natürlich hat
davor die republikation abzuspalten vom
stadtboss in Herzogenrath Bosnien zu
gewinnen zu zerstören der Hohe
Repräsentant für Bosnien und Herzegowina
Christian Schmidt der über Start und
Verfassung Wachen soll fordert schärfere
Maßnahmen der EU gerade im Bereich von
Sanktionen oder repressiven Maßnahmen
das heißt auch einfach den finanzstrom
zu kappen dass da noch nicht alle
Möglichkeiten ausgereizt sind
profitieren von der schrittweisen die
Stabilisierung an einem starken Bosnien
und Herzegowina hatten beide keinen
Interesse
die Zahl der Gewalttaten von
Jugendlichen gegen seit 2015 stetig
zurück bis 2021 im vergangenen Jahr hat
die Gewalt jedoch wieder zugenommen eine
Studie des kriminologischen
Forschungsinstituts Niedersachsen zeigt
Gewalt anzuwenden scheint bei
Jugendlichen akzeptierter geworden zu
sein
ein bisschen gewalt gehört einfach dazu
um Spaß zu haben oder wenn ich zeigen
muss was ich drauf habe würde ich auch
Gewalt anwenden solchen Aussagen
stimmten 2013 noch gut
13,9% der Befragten zu
2022 waren es schon
25,9%. sarattacke berichtet
Gewalt in der Schule gefilmt geteilt und
immer wieder auch Übergriffe auf der
Straße auf Polizisten und Rettungskräfte
hier an Silvester in Berlin-Neukölln
dabei war die Zahl der Tatverdächtigen
unter 18 nach einem Höhepunkt Anfang der
2000er eigentlich rückläufig bis jetzt
denn von 2021 auf 22 zeigt die Statistik
einen deutlichen Anstieg
sie sind eine Spezialeinheit gegen
Jugend Gewalt in Berlin ihre Aufgabe
Straftaten verhindern und aufklären
Polizisten die sich auch als
Sozialarbeiter sehen mit besonderem
Draht zu potenziellen Problemen
Jugendlichen so Polizisten mit Uniform
richtig respektlos aber die die sind
richtig so der mein Herz
als Kriminelle die sehen uns Kinder wir
sind Kinder wir wollen Spaß haben
den ganzen Tag draußen ist Langeweile
hat und irgendwann kommt weil sie
entweder auf die falschen treffen
eine aktuelle Studie aus Niedersachsen
zeigt dass Gewalt unter Jugendlichen
wieder hipper wird und das nach jeder
dritte der Befragten männlichen
Jugendlichen zumindest ab und an eine
potenzielle Angriffswaffe wie ein Messer
oder ein Schlagstock in seiner Freizeit
mit sich führt
warum man immer mehr Jugendliche Messer
und Schlagstöcke dabei es ist wie eine
Art Mode Mode kann man auch nicht
wirklich erklären aber wenn es einer
macht macht das der nächste nach und das
haben wir sehr stark festgestellt wenn
Freunde Messer tragen dann mache ich das
auch er vermutet auch das Filmen und
Verbreiten von Gewaltvideos könnte ein
Grund für die Zunahme sein wichtig sei
nun frühzeitig gegenzusteuern
am Puls mit Sarah Kacke kein Respekt
wenn Jugendliche zuschlagen die
komplette Doku sehen Sie heute Abend um
7:15 Uhr oder jetzt schon in der
Mediathek
höre Bildung das bedeutet auch sich für
Fortschritt in der Welt einzusetzen dazu
rief Papst franziskus heute Studierenden
Lissabon auf wo zur Stunde auf dem
Weltjugendtag viele tausende bei einer
Feier des Kirchenoberhaupt offiziell
bekommen heißen bei der größten
katholischen Veranstaltung der Welt wird
mit hunderttausenden mehrheitlich junger
Besucherinnen und Besucher gerechnet
zuvor hatte sich der Papst in einer
bildungsstiftung mit Pinsel und Farbe
versucht und ein großes Wandbild
vollendet
morgen ist der Wind weniger ruppig als
heute und zumindest am Vormittag lässt
sich auch mal häufiger die Sonne sehen
mehr zum wettergleich von Katja
horneffer Christian Sievers hat um 21:45
Uhr das heute journal für Sie auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend eine ansehnliche
sturmzyklone ist dieses Tief Xan das in
den vergangenen 24 Stunden entlang der
Nordseeküste weitergezogen ist bis nach
Dänemark es brachte uns viel Regen mit
aber auch Schauer und Gewitter die
Gewitter erkennen Sie an den kleinen
gelben Blitzen und es gab viel Wind auf
dem Brocken im Harz gab es heute eine
Orkanböe mit 144 km pro Stunde der Regen
lässt jetzt im Laufe der Nacht mehr und
mehr nach und die Temperaturen sinken
auf Werte zwischen 16 und 10 Grad dabei
wird es z.B im Schwarzwald und doch
lässt sich das reins am kühlsten der Tag
morgen bringt uns dann Temperatur von 18
Grad am Alpenrand und 24 Grad in der
Lausitz und vormittags zeigt sich noch
mal häufiger die Sonne nordöstlich der
Elbe es gibt schon die ersten
Regenschauer und der Regen breitet sich
am Nachmittag dann weiter aus da sind
dann auch wieder Gewitter dabei am alten
Rand setzt Dauerregen ein zwischen dem
Allgäu und dem Berchtesgadener Land
können innerhalb von 24 Stunden bis
Samstag früh 30
bis 50 in Stau lagen sogar bis zu 70
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter fallen und
wechselhaft geht's dann auch über das
Wochenende hinaus weiter guten Abend